[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace Norteamérica es un
gusto saludarlos desde Washington en
esta edición haremos un resumen de los
eventos políticos más importantes en
Estados Unidos en el último año
hablaremos sobre la polémica decisión de
la Corte Suprema de Justicia de
desconocer el aborto como un derecho
constitucional y sus impactos políticos
analistas demócratas y republicanos
descontarán cómo queda el ajedrez
político tras a las elecciones de medio
mandato y finalmente consultaremos a los
ciudadanos en Washington si creen que
biden tiene el capital político para
gobernar los dos años que le quedan sin
el control en el legislativo
[Música]
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia de mayoría conservadora en el
caso rubyway es uno de los temas que más
repercusiones políticas ha tenido en
Estados Unidos desconocer el aborto como
un derecho constitucional y cederle a
los estados del poder para regularlo
generó que al menos tres estados lo
prohibieran inmediatamente después de la
decisión de la corte y en otros Trece
más se esté debatiendo el tema para
restringirlo en Alabama en Kentucky en
Arkansas y Luisiana por ejemplo está
prohibido Incluso el aborto en Casos de
violación o incesto revertir el caso
rubyway llevó a grandes protestas en
todo el país y fue el argumento central
del partido de Joe biden en las
elecciones de medio mandato así lo
Argumenta Patricia Sosa analista
demócrata y exfuncionaria de la
administración de Bill Clinton
te diría que una de las razones por la
que los demócratas han vuelto a ganar
viabilidad política y fuerza política ha
sido la decisión del tribunal supremo
sobre el aborto las mujeres se están
movilizando y han hecho una gran
diferencia los jóvenes especialmente las
jóvenes se están movilizando y el tema
del aborto demostró ser uno de los temas
más importantes en las elecciones de
medio tiempo que hizo una gran
diferencia especialmente en estado como
Pensilvania como Michigan Y también
Arizona y Nevada donde el los candidatos
republicanos tomaron unas posiciones muy
conservadoras y los votantes se
sintieron que su voto sí contaba para
permitir la legalización las elecciones
de medio mandato en noviembre fueron un
termómetro para la administración de Joe
biden pero también para el expresidente
Donald Trump las encuestas y
proyecciones indicaban que el partido
republicano ganaría por un amplio margen
sin embargo la llamada marea Roja nunca
se produjo los demócratas tuvieron el
control en el senado y perdieron la
cámara de representantes por pocos
escaños ahora con las dos cámaras de
legislativo divididas entre partidos se
espera una parálisis legislativa en los
próximos dos años frenando la agenda
política de Joe biden para Arthur esto
opinan analista republicano y ex jefe de
gabinete en el congreso el resultado de
estas elecciones legislativas demostró
que el partido republicano debe pensar
más allá de Donald Trump si quiere
volver a ganar unas elecciones generales
Pero la realidad es que el estilo de
presidente Trump que no es un político
tradicional es mucho campo y para en la
política se necesita a todo el mundo no
solamente el 35 el 30 o 35% de los votos
americanos es importante necesitamos más
del 50 por ciento entonces la realidad
es que el pueblo americano está dividido
entre los republicanos y demócratas y
necesitamos los republicanos un
candidato
presidencial que tenga menos tonos más
positivos menos negativo hacia el resto
del país en las calles de Washington le
preguntamos a sus ciudadanos si creen
que vayan a poder seguir gobernando
ahora que no tiene el poder legislativo
y las dos cámaras del congreso están
divididas va a ser muy difícil pasar
cualquier tipo de legislación sin
controlar la cámara de legisladores pero
si acaso lo que me gustaría es que
pasara en algo de de legislación para
combatir el cambio climático creo que va
a ser una batalla cuesta arriba pero una
que vale la pena luchar creo que con
buenas coaliciones y relaciones
cualquier cosa es posible creo que vamos
a tener un cuello de botella por los
próximos dos años de pronto habrá la
posibilidad de hacer algo de Progreso a
través de órdenes ejecutivas a lo mejor
puede haber consenso en temas de interés
mutuo eso es lo que creo que va a pasar
no soy muy optimista las polémicas
decisiones de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia y los resultados de las
elecciones de medio mandato en el
congreso favorecieron políticamente a
Joe biden quien había empezado el 2022
con muy poco apoyo popular da la crisis
inflacionaria hoy el presidente tiene
una aceptación del 46% en comparación al
41 que tenía en octubre antes de las
elecciones legislativas el partido
demócrata está mucho más Unido y
respalda al presidente en su proyecto de
redistribución de ingresos y de lucha
contra el cambio climático proyectos
aprobados en la ley de inflación
políticas Además del ejecutivo que según
la administración tendrán efecto visible
para los estadounidenses en los próximos
dos años
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos en esta
edición de enlace Norteamérica desde
Washington pueden enviarnos a nuestras
plataformas y redes sociales comentarios
y sugerencias de temas que les gustaría
que exploremos en el programa Los invito
a seguir con la programación France 24
en español Hasta pronto